JENNY BROWN: Before you can
use the power of the Cloud
to serve your content, you
have to get your data into it.
In this episode of
Cloud Storage Bytes,
we talk all about the
ways you can upload data.
So buckle up, because
we're heading to the Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When it comes to writing
data into Cloud Storage,
you have a few
different options.
First is the easiest option--
using the Cloud Console.
This provides you with
an in-browser experience
where you can easily click
to create buckets and folders
and then choose or
drag and drop the files
from your local
machine to upload.
Second is the command line tool.
While the Cloud Console is fine
for easy uploads and simplistic
serving situations, for
production environments,
you often need an automated
command line solution.
For this, we provide
the gsutil tool.
Gsutil is a Python
application that
lets you access Cloud Storage
from the command line.
It provides you with the ability
to do all sorts of things
like creating buckets, moving
objects, or even editing
metadata.
To use it, simply run
the gsutil program
with a variety of
command line options.
For example, this command
uploads the directory
of files from your local
machine to your Cloud Storage
bucket using parallel upload.
And this command lists
out specific objects
that have a version specific
URL using a wild card.
You can see the other
cool stuff this tool can
do in the documentation
linked below.
Up next is our client libraries.
At some point, you might need
to interface with Cloud Storage
directly from your code,
rather than going out
to a command line option.
You can include the client
libraries into your code
and call a simple API to get
data into a bucket or folder.
And regardless of your
language, we've got you covered.
And finally, if none of
that suits your fancy,
there's always the good
old JSON and XML APIs,
which can let you
kick off an HTTP post
request to upload data
directly to a bucket or folder.
It's a bit more complicated,
but it's there if you need it.
Now, for you folks
with lots of data,
it's worth noting
that it might not
be feasible to upload
all of that data
directly from your on-prem
systems to Google Cloud.
For that, you can use the Cloud
Storage Transfer Appliance.
We ship you a fancy
device to your location,
you can connect it and
transfer at a super high speed,
and then send it back to us.
Plus, we get this cool looking
box on your desk for a while.
And don't worry if your
data is on another Cloud.
We've got easy-to-use
guides to help you get up
and running with supporting
a multi-Cloud environment,
getting data over to
Google Cloud Storage.
And of course, now that the
data is in Cloud Storage,
you've got to figure
out the best ways
to serve it to your
users worldwide.
But that's for another episode.
Subscribe, give
us a like, and let
us know what features
of Cloud Storage you'd
like to learn more about.
Thanks for joining us for this
Quick Byte of Cloud Storage.
[MUSIC PLAYING]